before we begin today's show we must
start off with a very important public
health announcement
by the very stable totally healthy guy
who wants to be your next president joe
biden
covet has taken this year just since the
outbreak
has taken more than 100 years
look here's the lives it's just
it's when you think about it more lives
this year than any other year
for the past hundred years you just you
think about it you think about more
more years and years and lives and years
and come on man
come on man i don't know about the
public health announcement i think
someone has to look into joe biden's
health and i think also we need to look
into the data new data on the
coronavirus
that continues to blow up the outrageous
alarmism and hysteria
pushed by political exploiters to lock
you up
and try to steal an election we'll get
into all of it i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from michael
great name typeantifa.com
into your browser just go ahead and do
it type
antifa.com into your browser
comes up as joe biden's campaign website
that is really great
it's a great little trick by whoever
bought antifa.com
and it gets to an important truth
because as we talked about yesterday
there is no meaningful difference
between
the black lives matter organization and
antifa and
the democratic party there is no
meaningful difference between the
rioters
who are burning down the country and the
political elites who are ordering them
to do so
now we've got to move from all these
questions of
race riots and madness into another
public health threat
the lockdowns and the coronavirus too i
guess but
more the lockdowns which we will get
into first though gotta thank our
friends over
at lifelock unless you secure yourself
on the internet
you are totally wide open to bad actors
trying to steal your stuff i don't know
how i can make this clearer
and i feel like i got to make it clear
because i used to not believe this
i use until people start trying to hack
into your stuff
people start trying to steal your stuff
especially right now with the increase
in cyber learning
very important to keep your kids
personal information safe make sure
they're not sharing any sensitive
personal information online
including anything that can help a cyber
criminal
steal their identity very very
important and now everyone is online all
the time whether it's work from home
whether it's distance learning
life lock detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised
they will send you an alert no one can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
you can find out if your information is
on the dark web
go get your free dark web scan at
lifelock.com
knowles you pick the plan that's right
for you you save up to 25 percent off
your first year
there's a free scan at lifelock.com
knowlescanwlis
and 25 off
let's get an actual public health update
six percent six percent you know what
that number
stands for six percent stands for the
number of people
who have uh died listed as a covid death
who have died exclusively from covid
who did not have other comorbidities who
did not have other underlying health
conditions
six percent this according to the cdc
you can still find it on the cdc website
but you can't find it on twitter because
twitter took down
this little unfortunate inconvenient
fact that 94
94 of covid cases
of covid deaths rather have involved
comorbidities
other factors this has been something
that we've seen i mean
this is not even a joke you could get
shot in the head
and be listed as a covid death that has
happened
there have been a lot of games that have
gone on with these statistics
here so far 183 221 deaths overall that
means
that 11 000 people just under 11 000
people
have died solely from covid
what's the median age of a covid death
median age of a covid death in the
united states is 80.
life expectancy in the united states is
78.6
twitter took down this fact because they
said well you don't understand how this
works
sure there might be other comorbidities
but that doesn't mean that it's not a
covid death
well yeah it doesn't mean that kovid
perhaps didn't contribute to the death
but what are we really looking at to
believe the mainstream media to believe
the democratic party
you have perfectly healthy young people
in the prime of their life
dropping like flies from coronavirus
but that isn't happening to believe the
democrats in the mainstream media
you've got young children who are
totally at risk from coronavirus that's
why they have to put them in those
bubble suits now
when they go to do their distance
learning at the schoolhouses that are
closed because you can't have in person
school you can only have distance
learning at the school
for some reason obviously
that is not the case either and twitter
takes it down
you won't find that go go search on
twitter find try to find the six percent
the big viral posts about this all taken
down in the name of disinformation
who's really spreading the
disinformation you know it's just like
the left always accuses trump of
spreading hate and racism
and division meanwhile the left is
burning down the entire country
and sowing hate and racism and division
well it's the same thing here
they have been spreading misinformation
about this virus about this lockdown
since day one and now when you try to
correct that information
using data from the cdc they take you
down for spreading fake news
here's another statistic ninety percent
ninety percent of people who test
positive for coronavirus
no longer are contagious this according
to the new york times by the way
in three sets of testing data that
includes cycle thresholds compiled by
officials in
massachusetts new york and nevada up to
90 of people testing positive
carried barely any virus they were not
spreading it
to other people now we've been told that
if you have no symptoms whatsoever and
no
no sign that you have this virus that
you're asymptomatic
and if you dare to leave your home you
are going to kill granny you're going to
kill
thousands and thousands of people now
what was that based on
nothing it was based on nothing that was
based on politicians
trying to get you to imprison yourself
for six or seven months
right now we're in september
we're in september we've been dealing
with the coronavirus since
february maybe end of january
when did the lockdowns take place march
march 15 days to slow the spread you
remember that
march well now summer's over now six
months of your life
gone can't go to stores you can't go to
work
you probably weren't able to take that
summer vacation
in l.a for long periods you weren't able
to go to the beach it's the only reason
to live in l.a
your life has been so dramatically
affected
did it need to be wasn't really that
affected by you know the asian flu
the h1n1 the wasn't
it wasn't this affected by the spanish
flu in 1918 that killed millions and
millions of people
so what happened here politicians that's
what happened here
you know i mentioned these statistics
but you have to be wary of statistics
conservatives need to be very wary of
statistics and there's nothing
anti-intellectual about that
we have to remember that there are lies
damned lies and statistics
we have to remember that statistics were
invented
for progressivism the word statistics
comes from
statist comes from the state it's it's
data for the state for the purpose
of serving the state it rose up with the
social sciences it rose up with
progressivism to basically
funnel this raw data into the
administrative bureaucracy to give them
a justification for passing the de facto
laws that they pass
whereas in the past we used to have
debate about these sorts of things so
you got to be very careful with
statistics
because statistics can be manipulated
and i got to tell you sure looks like
that's what's been happening for the
past
six months what about the death toll
there's a new
study out that shows that in fact
the cure was not just worse than the
virus
it was 10 times worse than the virus
we'll get to that in one second
first i got to thank our friends over at
puretalk usa
very frustrating as you know to pay for
something
then you find out you could have gotten
it somewhere for a way better deal
i know what you're thinking you say well
pure talk they probably have some
different cell network and it's
yeah sure it's it's okay but i want the
really
top ones i like whatever whatever i use
att verizon or whatever
what if i told you that pure talk usa
uses the
exact same network as one of those
characters
the exact same same towers same exact
coverage
but it costs you half you keep your
phone they send you a new sim card
you get the same great service you
currently have but at half the price
unlimited talk unlimited text and two
gigs of data
for twenty dollars a month twenty not
twenty plus eighty not twenty plus a
hundred
twenty the average person right now
saving four hundred dollars a year
with pure talk usa their customer
service also right here in the us their
ceo is a u.s veteran who understands
what it means to serve this country
right now you get unlimited talk
unlimited tax two gigs of data
for just 20 a month all you need to do
is grab your mobile phone
dial pound 250 say keyword michael
knowles that is pound or
hashtag 250 and say keyword michael
knowles when you do you will say 50
off your first month there's a new
uh study this came out in revolver
the covid19 lockdowns
are 10 times deadlier than
the virus 10 times deadlier
who could have predicted that who could
have called that oh yes we could have
called that on this show
six months ago we suggested this sort of
thing a lot of people did i want to just
take credit for that a lot of people
said gosh guys when you shut down the
global economy and imprison people in
their homes
for months and months at a time you know
drug overdoses might go up
suicides might go up unemployment the
obviously deaths of despair
other issues might come up and it's true
how did they calculate this
they calculated this in terms of years
of life
lost by american citizens so
the lockdowns in the united states are
estimated to have saved
a quarter to three quarters of a million
life years
right so one year of life for one person
that would be a life year
so the lockdowns to their credit did
save a quarter to three quarters of a
million life years according to the
study
however the lockdowns cost us an
estimated
18.7 million life years
so would seem to me i'm no math genius
that it wasn't quite worth it
and yet we're still doing it aren't we
there's no real plan to reopen in
california
what's the plan to reopen in other
cities around this country
new york maybe a little bit dc maybe a
little bit
15 days to slow the spread was announced
in the middle of march
speaking of death the left
wants our country to die that sounds
like an over-the-top headline doesn't it
sounds like a parody of what a
conservative might say the left wants
our country to die
well what if i told you that right now
separate from the virus because you know
the virus is
very contagious if you're a conservative
but if you're a leftist gathering by the
thousands in the streets not contagious
at all there are
gangs of leftists gathering around the
country
chanting death to america
take a listen to oakland california
there there's a lot of them not socially
distanced
[Music]
if you weren't going to expect some kind
of foreign accent
you could think that that was taken on
the streets of tehran
you could think that that was taken on
the streets of
saddam hussein's iraq you could think
that that was taken
somewhere in the world where people hate
our guts
but it's not it's actually from
california it's actually from oakland
they're not hiding it anymore when colin
kaepernick started his anti-american
protest
now years ago he took a knee for the
star-spangled banner for the american
flag
and i said at the time and i know a lot
of conservatives said huh that's
disrespectful that's very wrong
they said no he's not protesting the
country he's protesting
police brutality i said well that's kind
of weird because the american flag is
not a symbol of police brutality it's a
symbol of
america and he's protesting that he said
no it's police brutality you just don't
understand
he's just doing it for racial justice
whatever that means
then he started protesting the betsy
ross flag then they
started to burn the american flag now
they are chanting out and out
death to america
what more do we need to know you know
there's this thing that we we try to do
especially conservatives try to do this
because we try to be really nice people
we say look the left
they love their country too we love our
country and so we
hoist the american flag and celebrate
america's traditions
and recognize the fourth of july and
revere our founding
fathers and you know so we that's how we
celebrate america
and the left the way they express their
love for america is by burning down the
flag in the entire country but those are
just different ways
of of celebrating your country and you
can't say
that one side doesn't love america i
think if you're chanting death to
america
i'm gonna go out on a limb and say you
don't particularly love
your country now where does this come
from well a lot of it comes from the
racial
hatred that has been stoked that has
been intentionally
pushed by the left by elected democrats
and by the mainstream media and by the
university and by
big tech and by every other aspect of
the liberal establishment
so much so now that you you have a death
of america chant
tying into the blm chant tying into
not just black lives matter but tying
into the phrase
white lives do not matter which was
posted by a young man who ran up to
just a middle-aged white guy walking
down the street and smacked him in the
head with a brick
see the guy running up close up
clobber is this guy in the head goes
down and then feral animals
filming this across the street laugh and
joke and then say oh hahaha how great
that was
that this guy got smacked in the head
and what did they post
on instagram when this went up young man
you got knocked
tf out hahaha you bet not run
hahaha unk i don't know what that means
tried to kill yo white lives do not
matter black lives matter
this was another guy who was attacked in
another racial crime that you will never
see in the mainstream media obviously
if the racial roles had been reversed
here the country would shut down the
country already is shut down with race
riots but
it would have shut down again there
would be a call for a national
conversation about race
about white privilege about the systemic
oppression and the racism and the blah
blah blah blah blah
and instead what's going to happen this
video is going to be completely buried
by the mainstream media what would
possess
somebody to go up and do this sort of
thing to a guy
for what it would appear to be purely
racial hatred
what would possess somebody to giggle
and laugh while you film this happening
like a beast well you would have to be
so deep in the well of racial hatred
where did that come from didn't come
from nowhere didn't just bubble up from
the bottom
this was planned and pushed from the top
which we'll get to in one second first
though
got to thank our friends over at rock
auto you know
that uh in the heatwave in la i know
there was a heatwave going on the rest
of the country
the last thing you want to be doing is
sitting around waiting for your car to
get out of the shop
you don't want that rockauto.com makes
it so much easier
than walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers to things like
hey do you have the who's he what's this
for my doodad car or whatever you know
me i don't know a whole lot about cars
right
so when i'm talking to an actual car
part salesman at a brick and mortar
i am i am totally vulnerable they can do
whatever they want
i don't know prices i don't know nothing
rockauto.com makes it so easy because
first of all the brick and mortar
usually then doesn't have the part they
go online they probably order it from
rock auto they charge you twice as much
skip that part rockauto.com you can get
it at your desk and get it in your
pocket
they are a family business they've
served auto parts customers online for
20 years
they've always got the lowest prices no
gimmicks you don't need to worry about
that
and best of all their website is so
simple to navigate
even i can do it that's shocking
same prices for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers really great company
go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck
write nulls canon w l e s in there how
did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you
another one took place
uh just over the past few days 51 year
old white male was the victim of an
unprovoked stabbing at an auto zone
this was on august 25th the victim
was in critical condition but is now
expected hopefully to recover
why was he stabbed suspect was 19 year
old named jayvon hatchett
a black male who told the police that he
targeted this suspect who was an
employee at the autozone
because of his white skin he actually
told him this
so how did this guy how did this fellow
jayvon hatchet
decide that he was going to go out and
stab white people one day
he told the police he quote felt the
need to find a white male to kill
after watching videos of police
brutality
on social media look this guy might just
be a total psychopath who should be
thrown in the clink for his entire life
or worse
but let's take him at his word let's say
that he really was
just watching these videos of police
brutality on social media
and he got radicalized i think that's
true of a lot of people in this country
i think a lot of people in this country
even people who aren't going out
smacking people with bricks or stabbing
people
i think they seriously believe that
there is such a thing as white supremacy
or white privilege now there's no
evidence for this right
what is white privilege we only have one
legal system
of legal racial discrimination in this
country it's called affirmative action
it privileges black and hispanic
applicants it disadvantages white and
asian applicants to colleges and and
other institutions
that's the only one that's obviously not
white privilege that's why disadvantage
but they believe that that exists and
more than the privilege they believe
that there's a system of white supremacy
and white oppression
what does that look like they can't tell
you they tell you it's so
subtle that it only comes out in
microaggressions
and in the system and it's it's been
pushed
by uh people influenced by karl marx and
antonio gramsci and other thinkers for
over 100 years
and it's gotten worse in the last 50
years
that is continued to be pushed today
the you hear left-wing politicians top
left-wing politicians
joe biden stoking these flames joe biden
launched his presidential campaign
by saying that donald trump called nazis
and white supremacists very fine people
in charlottesville
that did not happen we've played the
tape many times
in the same two paragraphs where he says
the phrase very fine people he
explicitly says i'm not talking about
white supremacists and neo-nazis who
should be condemned totally
joe biden as utterly vacuous as he is
as totally declined as he is has to know
that he's just a liar
all of these guys are liars and these
lies have real world consequences
because if we're going to take this
this criminal from the autozone at his
word and and in some ways i do
that means that you've got a a
program a professionalized program in
this country of
liberal elites uh ginning up racial
hatred
for what they believe to be their own
electoral benefit and what you've got to
know about these liberal elites is that
they're liars they're stone cold liars
and they are ordering this from the top
joe biden tweet it out quote
this was yesterday tweeted it does
anyone believe there will be less
violence in america if donald trump is
reelected
now you might say oh this is joe being
wistful
or aspirational because he's saying we
need to elect me because only i will
come together and bring this
racial healing to america i'm just
worried it's you know i'm worried about
donald trump the same way a mobster
walks up and says gosh
nice restaurant you got here sure would
be a shame if something happened to it
it's a threat he's threatening people
if you don't believe that from joe biden
he's a little more subtle about it take
a listen to
to kamala harris in june who was asked
about the riots
on the colbert show and she said they're
not going to stop
i know that there are protests still
happening in major cities across the
united states i'm just not seeing the
reporting on it that i
that i had that's right for the first
few weeks um but they're not
stop they're not gonna stop and that's
they're not this is a movement i'm
telling you
they're not gonna stop and and everyone
beware
because they're not gonna stop it is
gonna they're not gonna stop before
election day in november and they're not
going to stop after election day
and that should be everyone should take
note of that on both levels that this
isn't they're not going to let up and
they should not and we should not
so first off she's encouraging the riots
which so many of the democrats
have done second notice how terrible
kamala harris is on tv
especially on colbert's show do you
remember that other clip where he said
hey remember when you called joe biden a
vicious racist she goes
it was a debate it was a debate it was a
debate it was a debate it was a debate
it was a debate it was a debate and
there was all she could only say those
three words
well same thing here it's not going to
stop it's not going to stop it's not
going to stop it's not going to stop
it's not going to stop
some creepy sort of mantra that she
keeps repeating but it's a mantra that
the whole left has been repeating
it's not going to stop until november
3rd until you elect us and maybe
it won't stop after november 3rd
guess it depends how you vote america
nice country you got there sure would be
a shame
if something happened to it these people
are calling for this from the top unless
you think that they actually believe
any of this nonsense that they're
peddling about white supremacy
or privilege whatever just remember
they're liars i'll just give one example
this is not a racial
or a covet example this is just on the
question of energy and the question of
of fracking for instance uh the trump
campaign put this out yesterday because
joe biden is saying that
donald trump is lying about him when
donald trump says
that joe biden wants to ban fracking
right he's lying about about joe biden
okay well
what joe biden doesn't realize is that
unlike in the 1980s when he thought he
could get away
with plagiarism and theft because we
didn't have home video now we've got
video right at our fingertips
let's play the tape i'm not banning
frackie
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including
coal and fracking in the biden
administration
no it would we would we would work it
out we would make sure it's eliminated
and no more subsidies
for either one of those either any
fossil fuel let me say that again
i am not banning frackie no matter how
many times
donald trump lies about me no more
no new fracking and by the way on the
recovery act
i was able to make sure we invested 90
billion dollars
in making sure we brought down the price
of solar
and wind that is lower than the price of
coal that's why not another new coal
plant will be built
i did that while you were watching
number one number two
we are we are gonna get rid of fossil
fuels
like what about say stopping cracking
and stopping
i guarantee you i guarantee you
we're gonna end fossil so not only you
gotta follow because he changes his
tunes so often
because joe biden blows in the wind but
he says i am not going to end fracking
yeah we're going to end fracking yeah
we're going to phase that fracking yeah
there's not going to be new fracking you
know there's not going to be more
fracking then at one point he says we're
going to end fossil fuels
and fossil fuels how are you going to
power your country on dreams
on hopes and dreams no they're not going
to have a country to power they're going
to lock everybody in their homes like
they have for the last six months
just one example because if they're if
joe biden is willing to lie to you about
that
effortlessly so blatantly
donald trump's lying when he says i'm
gonna end fracking look at the tape yeah
we're definitely gonna end fracking if
he's willing to lie about you
to you about that what else are they
lying to you about
we will get to that question in a second
because it ties in with a major case
of so-called police brutality uh which
we will get to first though
gotta thank all of you for subscribing
to the michael knoll show youtube
channel we are now close to 200
000 subscribers and you know you can get
us on youtube you can get us on apple
apple podcasts all sorts of things right
now you can get
daily wire on apple tv and roku
you know obviously i know you guys
listen on spotify facebook
probably myspace live journal i don't
know right now we're introducing a new
upgraded experience daily wire is on
apple tv and roku so members
can enjoy all of the visual elements of
this podcast on your big screen either
live or on demand
find the daily wire on apple tv or roku
download it today you have to be an
insider member to watch live so head on
over to dailywire.com
knowles use code watch at checkout get
15
off your membership purchase this deal
will not last long so act fast if you
want live shows on your big screen
plus the one of a kind highly coveted
one and only
leftist yours tumblr that is
dailywire.com knowles
get 15 off with code watch download the
daily wire on your apple tv and roku
today we'll be right back with a lot
more
jacob blake i'm sure you have heard now
the story the legend of jacob blake
the victim of police brutality allegedly
say his name the rioters tell us
jacob blake he was that guy who was
resisting arrest
remember and then he the cops have guns
drawn on him they tried to fire a taser
on him this guy like
invincible just walks around doesn't
matter walks over to a truck
opens up the truck full of kids reaches
in to grab apparently a weapon there was
a weapon hidden there in the truck and
then finally the cops shoot him
and this is called police brutality well
people are very upset
that jacob blake got shot not that he
resisted arrest not that he was had a
warrant out for his arrest anyway
but that he was shot fundraiser was
posted to gofundme
uh it has now raised over two million
dollars in donations that was as of
yesterday who knows how much
it's raised by today two million dollars
well what's the real story you ever
wonder
why all the pictures you see in the
mainstream media right all the pictures
are
jacob blake with his kid jacob blake
smiling probably jacob blake from the
seventh grade
sipping a juice box what a great guy
right well you
you have to ask why was there a warrant
out for his arrest
i know that's politically incorrect to
ask that question but
i asked it so then i did a little
research turns out
that the police who were involved in the
shooting of jacob lake were attempting
to arrest him for violating a
restraining order
that stemmed from an alleged sexual
assault
the alleged victim claimed that he would
just show up in her house
and sexually assaulted now some people
are calling him a rapist
and the initial reporting on this was
that he was a rapist it's not quite
the case but it certainly was a sexual
assault the
alleged victim told the police here that
she has known this man for eight years
and then he physically assaults her
around twice a year when he drinks
heavily
now i'd like to also caution the
conservatives here
we actually should give this guy his day
in court jacob blake
because believe it or not sometimes
people can make up
allegations don't forget brett kavanaugh
don't forget
many other times that we've seen this
especially in the metoo movement
however speaking of the metoo movement
where are the feminists where are the
leftists
to go after this guy aren't all women
supposed to be believed in hillary
clinton tell us believe all women
what about jacob blake's accuser who
says that he regularly goes over and
beats her and sexually assaults her
are we supposed to believe her no
because that that only suits the
feminist narrative which is sometimes
convenient not the racial narrative
which is convenient right now
now what do we what do we know for sure
about this guy jacob like we know there
was a warrant out for his arrest we know
he was resisting arrest we know he
while he had cops guns trained on him he
reached into a car full of kids and
tried to grab a weapon so i got to tell
you
doesn't seem like a great guy to me i'm
inclined to believe this allegation
just from what we know about this guy
jacob blake but even then he deserves to
stay in court
why is everybody rushing to the
conclusion that he's some kind of saint
the reason
they're doing it is because the media
and the democrats and antifa and blm
it's all the same thing and the
universities
it's all the exact same and big tech
could go on all day
they have painted an image for you of
this man that has nothing to do with
reality
drew clavin brings up this example a lot
you read the newspaper
you used to read the newspaper now i
guess you read the website you read the
newspaper
and you say wow oh my gosh i can't
believe that's happening in iran
wow oh my gosh i can't believe that
that's happening with that merger and
acquisition
and then you stumble across a story that
has something to do
with something that you know so say
you're a baseball player
or you're just a baseball fan you say
well i can't believe that's happening
with the yankees wait a second that's
not that's not happening
wait a minute no that story is not true
okay might as well read about all those
things i don't know about and believe
them
that doesn't make sense because if
they're wrong about one thing
they're very likely wrong about other
things if they're lying to you about one
thing
they're very likely lying to you about
other things if joe biden is going to
lie to your face about fracking
some you know in most people's lives a
relatively minor issue actually ver is
very important to your life but
in terms of your head space probably
doesn't occupy a lot of your time if
he's going to lie to you so blatantly
about that
what else are they lying to you about
you know they are now saying i don't
know if you watch the rnc
you saw that the rnc wanted to make this
big push to show republicans are not
racist
which i always think is sort of pathetic
and pandering that we
play into the left's accusations they
call us racist i think we should just
ignore them but
the republicans say no we're not racist
we're good people and i think we should
just ignore the democrats entirely
but regardless rnc made a big play to
show we're not racist
a lot of prominent black speakers other
minorities
the democrats are now telling you that
those black people who are republicans
who speak
at the republican party in some sense
they're not even black listen to tiffany
cross who's some person filling in
for the joy read show who's another
person who apparently has a show
on msnbc she described the rnc
as a minstrel show that was not a
saturday night live sketch
welcome back to am joy i'm tiffany cross
if you watched the republican national
convention
last week yet almost think that the
republican party
is the one welcoming people of color
given the big display of diversity
the convention featured more than a
dozen african-american speakers alone
but don't be fooled that the party of
trump
has suddenly warmed to the same people
trump's policies and sometimes his
rhetoric
directly harms as friend of the show
ellie missall wrote so eloquently in the
nation
the republicans invited a cadre of
professional
black friends to validate donald trump
and make
white people feel a little less racist
while
still very much supporting white
supremacy i mean i watched the
republican
convention and seeing the slew of
black speakers that they had it really
did
look like a modern day minstrel show to
me
a modern day minstrel show says the
woman
who in another breath says that all
black people need to think and say
exactly the same thing
a modern-day minstrel show says a
television network that forces black
people to only say
and think certain things and that
insists that black people can only say
and think certain things
a modern day minstrel show says
the modern day minstrel show that is
rich that is really rich
i want to hone in on one phrase there
black friend
ellie mistahl he's that kind of crazy
looking person who goes on left-wing
shows sometimes
elaine mustall said this that the gop
they just invited their black
friends and this is like a joke they say
what
the geople okay they've got their black
friends and these black friends of
theirs or what that's supposed to prove
that you're not racist
this goes into another point the left
often makes outside of the realm of
party politics they say
just because you have a black friend
doesn't mean you're not racist
they make fun of this they say you're
gonna deny charges of racism by saying
that you have black friends
and and they laugh at this as though
that would be so crazy
but if you do have black friends you're
probably not racist
that is the case right if you're if
you're friends with black people
then you probably don't don't hate black
people probably like some black people
not all black people or not all white
people either
it's it's this bizarre thing that the
left does
which is it's actually a good argument
to say no i'm not a racist look i have
black friends
and two just mock that they don't
explain why
that's not a good evidence that you're
not a racist they don't they don't
make any kind of argument they just
insinuate it's all insinuation it's all
laughing it's all derision
it's all mockery it's all scorn whenever
you see that mockery that's scoring that
sarcasm which is the last
refuge of a of a slow wit
whenever you see that that's good
evidence oh actually i've got a pretty
good argument here
and then she says the gop invites their
black friends
to prove that they're not racist when in
fact they support white supremacy
how does the gop support white supremacy
you don't have an answer makes sense
what is white supremacy
you don't have an answer good i am here
to tell you
that you should take white supremacy and
you should tuck that away
with the tooth fairy and the easter
bunny and santa claus
because white supremacy does not exist
no one can seem to define it no one can
seem to point to it
everyone says it's somewhere over there
but it's hidden
it's somewhere in that aggression but
it's micro it's somewhere
it doesn't exist it's a fake thing
you should you should ignore it you
should ignore it when people
use this ridiculous phrase it's not real
it's okay you can come out you can come
out at night the boogeyman
is not there there's nothing hiding
under your bed there's no white
supremacy
lurking in the closet so why do they
push it why do they push these imaginary
things
why do they push these ridiculous
arguments why are they so desperate
it's because president trump is making
some inroads with black voters now i
don't
i don't want this to be misinterpreted
as donald trump is going to win 50
of the black vote that's not going to
happen and i think sometimes
conservatives
overplay their hand a little bit but we
can measure it
there's a new hill harris survey shows
black support for trump black approval
of trump
soared after the rnc now by soaring
it still only went up to 24 so i'm not
saying
that the guy is going to win you know an
obama share
of black voters you're not going to win
95 or whatever 92 percent
however it's up nine points so what when
in in august this was taken august 11
through uh
august 8th through the 11th and black
approval of trump was 11 percent
it's now up or i'm sorry it was 15 it's
now up
nine points which is a 60 increase
that's a big jump
after the rnc the rnc clearly achieved
its purpose
and the democrats are so worried because
if the democrats ever were to lose
say 20 of the black vote i'm being very
ambitious here if
they lost 20 of the black vote they
would cease to be a national governing
party
they wouldn't exist they need to get
around 90
of the black vote to continue to be a
national party
and so they gin up that racial division
they have to it's an
existential question for them if they
ever
allow black voters to realize that white
supremacy is a complete
fiction they would lose their ability to
win
elections at the national level so they
talk about stupid nonsense
like adele's hair do you know adele i
don't really know it she's a singer i
guess
adele showed up and she put her hair in
some kind of knots
and she wore a jamaican flag bikini and
now people want to cancel her because
she's not allowed to do her hair a
certain way she's not allowed to wear
the flag
of another country because it's cultural
appropriation
now of course all culture is
appropriated culture
comes from cultivation it's what we
cultivate in ourselves when i read
tolstoy
i am not writing tolstoy i'm not pulling
that out of my own imagination
i'm appropriating something from russia
and that's good because it cultivates me
i am appropriating culture which all
culture must be
but they have to talk about this stupid
nonsense
or they have to encourage people to get
violent in the streets which they're
also doing
they have to burn the country to the
ground they have to lock people up
indoors they have to tell people they
can't go vote
even though there's no scientific reason
why people can't show up to vote they
have to do
anything they can to steal the election
because even though they have what you
would call now cultural hegemony
or political hegemony they run the
institutions
they run the administrative government
they do have so much power
it is fragile it could crack it could
crack if they just
they don't tighten that grip which is
exactly what they're doing
and it's working on a lot of people you
know i i said conservatives like to be
really nice guys
so we like to say ah look you can look
we love our country by waving the flag
you love your country by burning the
flag but i can't i could never say that
you don't love your country
this applies all the more so to religion
which is in religion you say look
the catholic church your local
christian denomination your temple they
don't have
a political point of view religion has
nothing to say about politics you can't
have politics and religion
or religion and politics and of course
the left never respects that they try to
infiltrate the churches
with all of their leftism but it's never
allowed to go the other way
this has confused many many faithful
people
otherwise faithful people including jim
gaffigan who's
famously catholic his wife he refers to
as a shiite catholic
and jim gaffigan practices the faith as
well
i hope he does but he seems very
confused he just tweeted out
look trumpers i get it as a kid i was a
cubs fan and i know you stick by your
team no matter what but he's a traitor
and a con man who doesn't care about you
deep down you know it i'm sure you enjoy
pissing people off but you know trump is
a liar and a criminal
f lou holtz the baseball coach biden
is catholic in name only compared to who
how many abortions did trump pay for
how many women has he raped how many
times did he pull the s-h-i-t he did in
ukraine
wake up he's a crook he's a con man by
the way no evidence that he paid for
abortions
no evidence that he raped women no
evidence that he did anything in ukraine
we know hunter biden and joe biden did
but not donald trump
wake up he's a crooked con man his
argument being
this this same stupid religious argument
word which is
you can't tell me that it's it's wrong
for
joe biden to pretend that he's a
catholic and then support abortions you
can't tell me that's
outrageous there's no right way to be a
catholic
that's there's there's no wrong way to
be a catholic at least there is
there is it is not acceptable
for catholics to vote for joe biden you
can't do it
you are imperiling your soul if you do
that
joe biden supports infanticide
up until the moment of birth paid for a
taxpayer expense
joe biden supports suing nuns he
faithfully served an administration
that sued nuns he promised if he's
elected again that he will sue more nuns
he persecutes the church there are many
other reasons too
a faithful catholic cannot vote for joe
biden
you are putting yourself in grave danger
if you do
you don't need to take my word for it
listen to a very courageous priest
by the name of father james altman who
puts it even more bluntly
but here's a memo to clueless baptized
catholics out there
you cannot be catholic and be a democrat
period their party platform absolutely
is against everything the catholic
church teaches
so just quit pretending that you're
catholic and vote democrat
repent of your support of that party and
its platform or face
the fires of hell yes virginia there is
a hell
there's a a well-known cleric who seems
to
be putting out there that oh hell is an
empty place
sorry buddy it's not what jesus said
jesus said
many are going to teach that broad road
to destruction only a few
are going to choose the narrow very
difficult road to the narrow gate
to heaven there will be 60 million
and county aborted babies standing at
the gates of heaven
barring your democrat entrance and
nothing you can say
will ever excuse you for your direct or
indirect
support of that diabolical agenda here
in the end
couldn't have said it better myself we
don't say this sort of thing
to be judgey you know to be really
downers and fire and brimstone and bible
thumpers or whatever whatever other
phrase you want to hear
we say these sorts of things as an act
of compassion
because the truth will set you free and
lies will ruin your life
here and and after here and in the
eternal
you know there's this left-wing premise
you see it especially with
transgenderism
that the truth is cruel and mean and you
shouldn't tell the truth
like that a man is really a man and not
a woman and that
lies are compassionate and comforting
and will help you thrive which they
won't they'll kill you
you've got to resist that temptation
you've got to realize that
the the truth is uh a very good thing
i know it seems like it should be so
obvious but now we're told don't tell
the truth
don't tell the truth about these
political questions how
how our religious views relate to
politics don't forget politics
downstream of culture culture downstream
of religion
because cult and culture come from the
same root word
don't tell the truth about that don't
tell the truth about white supremacy or
race in america because we just need to
let those democrats
try to maintain their absurd lock on a
certain voting demographic by spreading
lies that are so vicious
that they drive some people crazy enough
to attempt murder
don't tell the truth about the
coronavirus
because you know defer to the experts
better safe than sorry
listen to the authority unless the
authority contradicts the political
authority
of the democrats in which case we've got
to listen to them
that's a very cruel game that's very
harmful
to our health to our lives our health
here on this planet
our health as a nation and our life in
the hereafter
got to pay very attention there are
consequences to truth and lies
all right tune in tomorrow i'll be back
then i'm michael knowles this is the
michael null show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling
our national news cycle well tune in to
the ben shapiro show we'll get a whole
lot of that and much more
see you there